[music playing]
MALE SPEAKER: What
I'm eating isn't
giving me enough energy to
do what I need to do anymore.
And there comes a point where
it really, really escalates
into more of a starvation game.
Normally, I'm catching
fish with grasshoppers.
But as it's getting colder,
and the grasshopper are getting
harder to find, then I'm
finding I'm going to have
to do something different.
And I had an idea to
try and make a lure.
I took three of my
regular-size solid hooks.
I bound them together
with my wire.
I don't have an abundant
amount of hooks.
And I've realized how
important and vital
they are to, like,
everything that I do.
About an inch up, I took
some of my paracord,
and I frayed it all out and
made it like a hula skirt.
So, yeah, I'll go fishing
with this one tomorrow.
It's not pretty.
Doesn't have to be pretty.
[inaudible] this
guy's maiden voyage.
Not too shabby.
Very pleased with it.
I want to stay away
from the trees.
It's a huge difference
between those grasshoppers.
I have faith in this lure.
That was a strike.
Here we go.
Got one.
Oh, yeah.
Come on.
Oh, [beep].
I just lost my lure.
Damn.
That's a lot of hooks
to lose all at once.
Running low.
That's just--
that's unacceptable.
Well, my fishing game just
took a significant blow.
I'm in the midst
of mild starvation.
[music playing]